did we talk about that time we went to a
jojo bar last week or
i don't think we did so yeah because i
wanted to talk about the jojo
so yeah yeah to to explain uh like two
weeks ago
we went to the same jojo bar that uh
joey made a video on
and it was a [ __ ] i i i don't know
what is
about japan that has so many of like
these small bars that are like
themed yeah but they're like way cooler
than any of like them
like the big bars that you go to in the
west or that i've been to like in
england that tried to make like this
themed bar right you know what i mean
because it was so small and it was so
intimate and it was run by a guy who
clearly really [ __ ] loved jojo oh
yeah yeah and
i think the i think what impressed me
the most was the [ __ ] drink list
oh my holy [ __ ] yeah like
the because in my video as well and when
we got there
they say that you can film anything and
you take you can take photos and videos
of like any of the merch or anything
like that
but you can't take a picture or video of
the menu yeah for the longest time i
never understood
why like why only the menu yeah but then
when you actually flip through this menu
and you realize there's like
almost like a thousand [ __ ] drinks i
think there's like
it's got to be i'm counting my head like
maybe like around 300 drinks yeah
i'd say so but it's like more than like
your conventional like bombing yeah yeah
and
out of those like three four hundred
drinks half of them are originals it
just is original
yeah yeah and uh and they're all like
named after you know characters and
phrases and whatnot and you have to
[ __ ] like
perform the phrase as well to the
bartender
yeah and it's so like embarrassing when
like you say like if lion's like uh
excuse me can i get the
and then she's like okay one day
yeah because to explain how the menu
works basically the menu works like
like a [ __ ] it's the menu isn't it's
the jojo reference right
so it goes by parts so every drink is
either named after
a character or a stand or just a random
reference
yeah yeah like you know you have like a
random catchphrase or something
um was was there like a drinking
platform that that was like let's kills
the [ __ ] or something yeah yeah let's
kill the home let's kill the hogies
that was like there was like a reference
to like the dead dog in part one and one
of them
as well what was it oh yeah it was like
danny
that was his name yeah yeah yeah that
sounded like something like that and
then there was like oh my god there was
just so many funny
sounding ones like i just loved it there
was one bohemian rhapsody i mean that's
a stand
i just love that i could order a drink
called a bohemian rhapsody yeah i i just
i just found it super cool that i was
just basically basically ordering
a [ __ ] you know kira or chicago or
something like that you know you just
basically
you're just basically ordering jojo
references yeah i thought i was [ __ ]
brilliant
although there was one thing that i was
like kind of upset about
and i don't know if this is going to be
a spoiler for part seven but i was very
upset that i couldn't order a jesus
christ
oh yeah i would have lied the jesus
christ yeah i was looking through seven
i'm like please say this
was there a president of the united
states as well i don't think that was
either
i don't know no no i think there was a
was
there was funny valentine's day was
there was there not a george bush
george
it's like a character that's moral
laughter or something i don't [ __ ]
know but see what what i love about
being a jojo fan who's only watched the
anime hanging out with you two who have
like read way further in the manga
is that i was hanging out to this bar
and you would you were just like
straight up putting like out spoilers
for particular part seven
and the great thing about jojo is that i
was listening to these spoilers and i'm
just like
i don't think i've actually been spoiled
honestly
the only show that you can spoil without
actually giving anything away
so little sense that when you hear it
it's like you just don't see it ever
coming
when you're reading it like yeah so uh
in part seven dio turns into a dinosaur
because he's going after jesus christ's
arm and you're just like
i guess that's what happened that was my
exact same
that was my exact reaction like i knew
that happened but i didn't like when i
was reading it i was like
oh and i only realized it when it was
happening i was like oh
that's what everyone meant because out
of context it's like
how is this plot point supposed to fit
into the story in any sense
it's hearing it out of context it's just
it doesn't
uh hinder your enjoyment when you
actually experience the entire thing
yeah
which is why i'm i'm [ __ ] looking
forward to when i'm hoping
when part 6 part 7 has animated
um although hearing you guys talk about
it in the bar i might just like go out
and read it honestly
that's basically what they are what is
it all the memes where it's like a jojo
fans when they see an unsucked [ __ ] or
whatever is that what it is
yeah like the best part is though is it
like you don't know
if the drink like because it's just as
original right so you have no idea what
it is but you kind of got to guess is it
going to be like a
fruity easy to drink drink or is it
going to be like just [ __ ]
alcohol like yeah straight liqueur and
like joey just somehow kept ordering
like just he was like i'll have the re
and they were all just like basically
straight spirits
yeah i kept ordering stuff that was all
like malibu
fruity drinks i i actually think he has
a kind of like a power leveling system
going on with the drinks
because any time you'd ordered like a
main character or like a or like a jojo
um it was always a super powerful drink
yeah
i know like out of all the powerful
drinks i had i think the most powerful
one i had was
no it was part three dia was it really
three was like as well
as well was [ __ ] bad i had to
and then this cute bartender girl was
like okay
but here's something do you think he
actually remembers every drink that he
made because most of them are originals
i think so i
[Applause]
sex pistols comes on like a roulette
like like
a style table thing with a gun in the
middle yeah that's funny and then she
plays different shirts it's just
basically
six shots it's just perfect because it
shoots yeah
so you're going through the menu you
want you don't know how strong the drink
is gonna be
and like two you don't know what the
drink is going to be either
so it was just it was just a fun
experience just working your way through
the menu
and just being like hey this is this is
akira or this is like a sex pistols and
just being surprised at what you got but
i think as well that's such a
an awesome like marketing move as well
because that just incentivizes you to go
back
right right it's been like all right i
finished all the part one drinks this
time around
next week i'm gonna go back and finish
all the parts right
it's basically like watching jojo itself
you work through each part until you get
through every part you can't skip any of
the parts you have to like complete it
i watched how that was like five rohan
kishi bays it was like rohan kishore bay
heaven store rohan kishpe at the louvre
goes to gucci
my favorite one was when you'd order
like a jotaro and you have to like
specify which part
which part are you ordering yeah that's
so awesome
it's like i don't know i feel like those
kinds of establishments are just
the most perfect place to just weep the
[ __ ] out yeah because it's like
it forgives you for weaving out right
you get so drunk as well because you're
like you just want to keep [ __ ]
drinking right
and it's like reasonably priced it's
like i don't know like seven dollars a
drink yeah and all the all the cocktails
were delicious as well yeah
tastes are really really good even
though you know half of them [ __ ] me
up
because they were so [ __ ] strong i
just kept getting the straight shot and
i kept getting the nice ones and i'm
like oh yeah
i was like oh i want something nice
there's like soothes my throat after all
these [ __ ] people
then orders a [ __ ] sex pistol and
just gets just it's just straight up six
shots
it's not even a cocktail i love it that
was great
but yeah go check it out if you if you
guys are what was it called again
uh it's called uh yeah yeah
in tokyo so when the country opens up go
on uh separate visit they have a twitter
as well